a lot of ladies get a little
self-conscious a little embarrassed I
say queef it up sister it's nice to see
that thing talking for once
the quave I went down a girl once she
queefed my hair went
it's a hell of a time you got to be
empathetic to the queeze fellas because
ladies I think you're more empathetic in
general I think you're more thoughtful
you think about others man we don't
think about others we think about
ourselves like I'll go to dinner with my
girl say we can't eat here hurt the
chef's homophobic I'm like great we're
not gay we're good yeah
that's how I think man we don't think
about others I was watching a tennis
match with my buddy I go you know this
guy went to jail for hitting his wife my
friend goes oh yeah he's got a great
backhand Jesus Christ you're a little
deeper ladies a little more emotionally
intelligent like you ever ask a woman
what she likes in that guy she'll tell
you what she likes because of how it
makes her feel I like how it's big and
strong because I feel safe a lot of guys
got some money because I feel taken care
of guys we just tell you what we like we
don't tell you what we feel we like in a
woman Bob like a fat ass
how's that make you feel
hard